willkommen zur heutigen sitzung der geht
es um in amerika und seine theorie der
achtung und des mitleids und auch noch
ganz am schluss theorie der liebe im
kontext der frage was moralische gefühle
sind diese heutige sitzung versteht sich
als sitzung im kontrast zu den letzten
sitzung in der wir uns mit der video und
autoshow befasst haben und deswegen muss
ich ganz kurz noch ein bisschen auf
diese beiden dinge eingehen oben rechts
wie immer der link zur letzten sitzung
der diese beiden dinge behandelt wurden
und ich möchte ganz kurz die sachen
fassen aber auch natürlich noch ein paar
leitfaden für die heutige sitzung als
inwiefern sind nach kant mit leid und
liebe nicht als ursprüngliche
moralischen motivation geeignet oder
auch nicht als moralische gefühle im
strengen sinne anzusehen wie ein besitzt
das phänomen die achtung als emotion
eine gefühls eine urteilt und eine
motivation steam mission und in der
beschreibung mache ich noch mal den
artikel aus der stamford video
philosophie von scania untersucht hat
die sehr treffen zwischen diesen drei
dingen zu unterschieden haben und wir
können jetzt in der heutigen sitzungen
zu überlegen werden wie fern sich die
auch im moralischen gefühl der 800 kann
frieden lassen kann sprich nicht von der
emotionen kann sprich für ein gefühl
8 ich bin der meinung und das müssen
heute diskutieren dass es sich dabei
streng genommen meine emotionen handelt
weil sie diese drei dimensionen
besonders gut in sich begreift ja das
sind die frage jetzt noch mal kurz
zurück zur letzten sitzung also das ist
dem ju und der wiederum hatte dann eine
ganz komplizierte verschachtelte
einteilung gegeben von dem was er zu
einem englischen originaltext die
passions nicht da habe ich gesagt die
deutsche übersetzung ist affekte und ich
bin damit nicht ganz glücklich weil
effekte wie
ich glaube wie sie sind und wie wir sie
auch behandelt haben ist hier im seminar
sowas impulsives haben
und darunter würde zum beispiel hier
mitleid naja oder liebe jedenfalls
vielleicht auch neid nicht fallen
jetzt möchte ich aber noch mal kurz auf
die einstellung reingehen jugend spricht
von passion specials einmal gesehen von
lateinisch cassio griechisch passieren
heißt erleiden passion ist er häufig
eine leidenschaft als etwas wie man was
man gemüts erregung vielleicht besser
übersetzen könnte warum gemütsregung
weil es doch ein bisschen eine stärkere
form ist von ihnen war phänomenal i tät
als bloße 4 links aber darüber müssen
wir noch kurz leben juden teil alles
zuoberst einen perzeption perzeption
könnte man ganz allgemein sagen das ist
alles was den geist erfolg vor findbar
ist alles was ein phänomen ist ein
phänomenales bewusst sein könnte
das kann man der schönen eindrücken und
vorstellungen der vorstellung ich kann
zum beispiel ein goldenberg vorstellen
ein goldener berg ist eine kombination
aus gold der farben gold und der form
des berges das kann ich dann durch die
einbildungskraft zusammensetzen haben
ihre vorstellungen komplexe fürchten
das interessiert mich nicht interessiert
das was ein eindruck ist dass uns also
gegen die erreger gemütsbewegungen
beinhaltet natürlich können vorstellen
werden uns auch motivieren oder regen
die auch immer jedenfalls es geht um die
eindrücke jetzt erstmal unmittelbare und
stärker sind als die vorstellungen soll
die ein trick unterscheidet er im
premiere eindrücke das ist so was die
schmerz etwas hast die körperliche seite
hat ich würde sagen zum beispiel hunger
und das würde ich jetzt nach einer
technologie als gefühl bezeichnen
während es die primären eindruck davon
unterscheidet er die sekundären
eindrücke
die könnte man die effekte den weiteren
weiteren sinne bezeichnen die sind
reflexiv all die sich auf die primären
eindrücken ziehen nur bringt als
beispiel
ich empfinde schmerz als gefühl und dann
entsteht daraus als reaktion oder als
reflexion darauf die hoffnung weil ich
hoffe dass ich den schmerz irgendwann
nicht mehr haben oder die graben wie er
sagt dass ich denke hoffentlich und ich
denke der schmerz geht nicht wieder weg
aber der angst zu wachsen das als eine
reflexive gemütsbewegung gemünzt
erregung die auf seine premiere
rego folgt deswegen würde ich sagen oder
sagt auch junge sonders reflexive und
jetzt unterscheidet er nochmal zwischen
ruhigen sekundären eindrücken
das sind wir wie er sagt der schönheit
und hässlichkeit
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob meine
schönheit fühlen kann und hässlichkeit
deswegen finde ich es ihr passend davon
stimmungen zu sprechen man kann es sich
überlegen davon stimmung sprechen
es sind ruhige ruhige perfekte ruhige
gelöst tönungen die so etwas wie eine
betrachtung auch innerhalb der sagt die
werde ich etwas betrachten der schönheit
dreistigkeit
das würde ich sagen hat was von stimmung
ist diese ruhe diese kontemplative die
mission und die uns nicht so sehr mit
reichsten also stimmung hatten wir
gesagt die sind ihre kasse diebe lassen
uns kontemplativ diese nicht so radikal
und auf unterscheidet jugend noch mal
die heftigen reflexiven sekundären
revolutionen oder eindrücke die er
effekten entziehen wo ich noch zustimmen
würde aber erst im weiteren sinne
verstehen wozu er auch noch emotionen
nach unserem verständnis zählen nämlich
einen giebel hans kramer stolz und die
wiederum unterscheidet er direkte die
als schmerz verlust folgen wie zum
beispiel vorstellen kummer und indirekte
die als dann noch mal ein bisschen
reflexiv sind mit liebe
so also ich würde sagen nach unserer
technologie das hier
diese direkten heftigen sekundären
eindrücke könnte man affekte nehmen und
die in gelenken könnte man emotionen
nach unserem verständnis wäre diese
ruhige sekundären eindrücke könnte man
stimmungen und die premieren hier könnte
man gefühle sind versucht so macht es
anders er hat eine andere einteilung er
geht immer von wo ich und heftig direkt
und direkt aus ich weiß nicht ob diese
opposition so die ganze einschließt ich
glaube dass man es noch anders machen
kann aber darüber können wir treffen
diskutiert darüber kann man auch sehr
schöne hause beispielen so viel zur
einteilung bei der video und jetzt noch
als kleiner nachtrag auto schopenhauer
der in seiner schriften sein buch die
welt als wille und vorstellung die
ersten mal lag 819 erschienen noch ein
bisschen was zum mitleid 8 trägt nach
schopenhauer gilt zitat dass ein solcher
mensch der in allen wesen sicht sein
innerstes selbst erkennt auch die
endlosen leiden alles lebenden das
designen betrachten und zu den schmerzte
ganzen bild sich zu eigenen muss ihm ist
kein leid mehr fremd alle qualen anderer
die er sieht und zu selten zu lindern
verlag alle qualen von den iren
mittelbar kunde hat ja die er nur als
möglicher kennt wirken auf seinen geist
wie seine eigene es ist nicht mehr das
wechselnde wohl und wehe seiner person
das im auge hat wie dies bei dem noch im
egoismus fangen menschen der fall ist
sondern eher das prinzip wie um in die
situation ist also das prinzip der
individualisierung als uns zu individuen
macht durchschaut
gebt ihm alles gleich nach er kennt das
ganze fast das wesen des selben offen
findet in einem steten vergehen
wichtigem streben inneren widerständen
beständigen leider begriff sieht wenn er
auflegt die leidenden
an die leidende tier hat und eine der
kinder schwimmt in die welt dies alles
aber linken jetzt mal mit dem egoisten
und seine eigene person
wie sollte er nun bei solche erkenntnis
der welt eben dieses leben riskierte
willensakt evian und eben dadurch sich
ihm immer feste verknüpfen lässt immer
fester an sich drücken also im mitleid
oder bleiben erkennen wir dass alles
miteinander zusammenhängt
und dass wir eigentlich dieses leiden
verneinen sollten und nicht eben durch
individuelle erkenntnisse individuelle
handlungen gewarnt sollte das ist ein
zitat das zeigt dass der schopenhauer
geben das mitleid nicht nur ein gefühl
ist also ein affekt oder emotion
es sind eigentlich eine metaphysische
erkenntnisse auch beinhaltet sogar noch
eine normalität hat darüber kann man
sich jetzt streiten das jetzt er ist
immer anerkannt und zudem soll es heute
eigentlich gehen und zwar informationen
also 1804 gestorben 1724 geboren
er war wie dutroux ein philosoph der
aufklärung aber ein ganz
entgegengesetzte denker mit blick auf
die vernunft im gegensatz zu jung ist
die vernunft nach kant nichts klar wenn
der effekt
jung sagte slomka schon sondern die
vernunft kann eigenständige zwecke
setzen sie kann mit effekten kuriere und
selbst ein gefühl autorisieren
autorisieren neben hervorbringen
bedingungen rechtfertigen das ist dieses
gefühl beachtung wiedersehen werden
qualität muss ich nach kann durch die
praktische vernunft erkennen lassen die
ist also gerade nicht dem ein schönes
unter grauem übergeordnet und die
praktische vernunft muss
selbstmotivation aale quelle der rat
sein also nach kant muss die vernunft
nicht nur uns die moral erkennen lassen
was moralische lösung ist an sich muss
selbst auch das motivation spreads mit
sich bringen was uns dann auf zu handeln
muss
das darf nach kannten nicht aus der
ziemlich kite
das sagt nicht aus der bereich der
gefühle revolution perfekten stand dafür
hatte verschiedene argumente und die
wollen wir heute auch noch kurz
versuchen uns verständlich zwar jetzt
erst mal dass der unterschied zwischen
vernunft und gefühl oder auch neigung
und triebe wir müssen dazu sagen kann
differenziert hier nicht verstaubt er
wirft da eigentlich alles in einen topf
das nicht vergessen hat dass auf die
seite der inter noch nie gehört also in
dem was wir empfinden das wir leiten was
sie fühlen da sind wir nicht frei und
selbstbestimmt gegensatz zu vernunft das
wesentliche sagt der alle bestimmen des
films durch sittliche gesetzt ist dass
sie die gesetze in kategorie schnell ein
paar devisen gesetzt dass er als freier
wille mithin nicht bloß ohne mitwirkung
sinnlicher antrieben dann selbst mit
abweisung aller deshalb und mit abbruch
anhaltungen sofern sie jenem gesetze den
sieben gesetzen zuwider sein können bloß
durch gesetz bestimmt wird
das ist jetzt also genau das gegenteil
von jungen seien mit abweisung also mit
ablehnung mit beherrschen können wir
auch sagen der nikon also die
vernünftiges nach kant gerade nichts
laufen person sondern sie ist master auf
dem carl schurz kantonsrat das wirklich
zu der fall ist darüber kann man
trefflich streiten da wurde auch
trefflich darüber gestritten wie sein
kann
er sagte zu mitleid eine heilung ist
blind und knecht magd und gutartig sind
nicht um die vernunft wo es auf
sittlichkeit ankommt muss ich bloß den
vormund der selten vorstellung also
master nicht live sondern ohne auf sie
rücksicht zu nehmen als reine praktische
wirft ihr eigenes interesse ganz allein
besucher selbst dieses gefühl des
mitleids und der barmherzige teilnehmer
wenn es vor der überlegung als pflicht
sein vor hier geht und bestimmungsort
wird ist wohl denkenden personen selbst
lästig print ihre überlegte maximen
zwirn und bewirkt den wunsch ihrer
entledigt und allein der gesetzgebenden
von uns unterworfen zu sein
also mitleid ist zumindest nicht der
kandidat für moralische motivation
premiere warum weil sie zur sinnlichkeit
oder zuneigung gezielt werden kann und
ihre maxime ihre grundsätze in
verwirrung bringt also mitleid hat keine
klare orientierung im mitleid werden wir
hingerissen
das sind ja auch irgendwie hetero nom
bestimmt shoppen haben würde sagen aber
das ist auch gerade wichtig für die
normal dass wir hingerissen sind nicht
groß nachdenken weil wenn wir jetzt
große nachdenken würden was ich tun soll
wenn ich das schon zu spät
dann habe ich gerade nicht diese
motivation die ich hier von riskanten
braucht denken sie eine szenerie wie ein
kleines kind ins wasser fällt und sie
unmittelbar das mitleid oder wie auch
immer aus moralischen motivation
hinterher springen das ist nicht direkt
mit leiden oder sie sehen irgendein kind
bleiben
die wasserskier trinken und dann
springen sie hinterher denken sie nicht
viel nach das würden viele auch
phänomene nur bestätigen dass das zu
moralität gehört nicht groß nachzudenken
ist aus ohne über ein puls
herauszuhandeln
ganz sagt nein wir sollten hier immer
erst aktivieren und ein maximen
testverfahren in gang setzten
schopenhauer hat sich dann später
darüber lustig gemacht und gesagt das
ist das breite ruhepolster der moral
man kann sich auf dem kategorischen
imperativ ausruhen aber motivieren kann
ein nicht erkannt würde sagen der
kategorische imperativ ist kein
ruhepolster sondern ein nadelkissen weil
der kategorische imperativ uns immer
wieder auffordert zu handeln und zu
lieben dann genug sagen kann hängt dann
auch mit dem gewissen zusammen gewissen
wir überhaupt eine frage ob das ein
gefühl ist emotion dann noch jetzt zur
achtung jetzt kommt kein konkret zu acht
und versprechen er sagt erstmals
selbstkritisch man könnte mir vorwerfen
als suchte ich mir den worten achtung
nur zuflucht in einem dunklen gefühle
anstatt es durch einen begriff der
vernunft in der frage deutlich auskunft
zu geben
nein mit achtung gleich ein gefühl ist
so ist doch kein durch einfluss
empfangen ist also nichts hätte es keine
neigung sondern durch einen
vernunft begriff selbst gewähltes gefühl
und daher von allen gefühlen ersteren
art die sich auf neigungen oder
vielleicht bringen lassen
spezifisch unterschrieben weil sich
unmittelbar als gesetz wenn ich erkenne
da erkenne nicht mit achtung welche bloß
das bewusstsein der unterordnung meines
willens unter einem gesetz wolle
vermittlung anderer einflüsse auf meinen
sind bedeutet also man erkennt etwas mit
acht kommen die achtung ist das
bewusstsein der unterordnung weiß linz
unter das gesetz also hier kommt jetzt
ganz kleine kognitive dimension zum
vorschein
man könnte auch sagen nach diesem stand
von enzyklopädie artikel hier hat die
achtung die funktion eines urteils kann
erkenntnis eine art von proposition ich
erkenne dass mein wille in der siebten
gesetz ordnet ist weiteres zitaten
unmittelbar bestimmung des willens
durchsetzt und das bewusstsein der
zeiten heißt achtung so dass diese als
wirkung des gesetzes aufzug lebt und
nicht als ursache angesehen wird
eigentlich ist achtung die vorstellung
von einem wert der mine dass selbst die
abbruch kommt also ist eine vorstellung
was das cockpit urteil könnte was also
ist es etwas was weder als gegenstand
der bergung noch der furcht betrachtet
wird und gleich ist mit beiden zugleich
quast analoge schuss hat es hat etwas
kind streben das und etwas weg streben
das ist also eine ambivalenz die
gegenstand der achtung ist also
lediglich das gesetz das ist ein gesetz
und zwar das jährige dass wir uns selbst
und doch als an sich notwendig auf
erleben als gesetz sind wir ihm
unterworfenen ohne die selbstliebe zu
erfragen
als uns selbst auferlegt es ist doch
eine folge unseres willens und hat in
der ersten rücksicht aloe mit furcht in
der 2 mit neigung okay also es hat etwas
von furcht und
etwas gegen stress ist ein ambivalentes
gefühl dass gefühlte acht er sagte alle
achtung für eine person ist eigentlich
nur 48 gesetz sind von jene die person
und das bei spiegelt ok also die achtung
geht gar nicht auf die person die
internationalität achten sondern sie
geht auf eingesetzt bis jetzt ist aber
etwas kognitives etwas proposition alis
nennen das gesetz sagt dass du dass er
das machen sonst also hier kommt wieder
die urteils dimension der achtung durch
gut zu kennen und genau jetzt kommt
diese normale lenz des positiven
negativen zur sprache die die gefühl
zeit der achtung das ist ja auch eine
dimension von investitionen betrifft er
sagt das wesentliche alle bestimmungen
des wilds durchschnittlich gesetzt ist
dass er als freier wille mit dir ich
bloß ohne mitwirkung sind vertrieben
denn selbst mit abweisung alle der seele
und mit apricot und sofern sie jedem
gesetzt hat wieder sein könnten
bloß durch gesetz bestimmt hatte hier
wieder master of the passion ist soweit
ist also die wirkung des moralischen
gesetz als triebfeder nur negativ und
als solche kann die dreht wieder apriori
erkannt werden denn alle neigung und
jeder ziemliche antrieb ist aufs gefühl
gegründet und die negative wirkung aufs
gefühl durch den abbruch der den eigenen
geschmack ist selbstgefühl also das ist
jetzt der punkt wo kann sagt die achtung
selbst ist ein gefühl sie hat eine
gefühl seite sie hat erstmals negatives
kann wird jetzt gleich sagen das ist der
schmerz das ist der schmerz ein gefühl
des schmerzes was er mit der achtung
zusammenhängt dass bestimmte jetzt ein
bisschen genauer gesagt alte schlägt das
moralische gesetz dem alge dunkeln
nieder hier sehen wir wieder ganz klar
dass das eine master eine meister der
herrschaft technologie da diese
gesetz aber noch etwas einzig positives
ist nämlich die form einer
intellektuellen qualität dass es der
freiheit so ist es in dem es gegensätze
mit dem subjektiven wieder spielen
nämlich den neigungen in uns schlecht
zugleich entgegen stand der acht und in
dem es die zucker niederschlägt das ist
gegenstand der größten achtung mithin
auch der grund eines scans positiven
gefühl dass nicht algerischen ursprungs
ist und apriori erkannt wird alles
achtung fürs moral des stillens ein
gefühl welches durch einen
intellektuellen kontrolliert wird und
dieses gefühl ist das einzige rechten
völlig a priori erkennen und dessen
notwendigkeit mehr einsehen können also
hier kommt jetzt auch noch die positive
seite und spielt die aus dieser
schwächung des eigenen dunkels alle das
jeden gelassen egoismus ausmacht
betrifft ja hier sagt er noch mal davon
also dass die negative wirkung aufs
gefühl als unannehmlichkeit bestimmt
werden kann beachtung und aber auch eine
positive positiven grund wir hier finden
und zwar im urteile der vernunft weder
der urteils aspekt gebe es das beratungs
gefühl den widerstand der jungen aus die
jägerschaft die vae krönung eines
hindernisses einer positiven befunde
qualität gleichgesetzt
also wenn das moralisch zu viel
beachtung und demütigt und unseren
eigenen weg räumt dann kann man es aus
einer anderen perspektive zu sehen dass
da etwas ermöglicht wird dass da ein
widerstand aus dem weg geräumt wird und
etwas was sein soll nämlich unsere
vernunft wie der raum bekommen so das
ist also eine positive die beziehung
jetzt müssen wir noch genauer schauen
wie diese positive dimension genannt
werden kann
die negatives erkannt diese
einschränkung tut nun eine wirkung
gefühl und bringt empfindung der unlust
vor allem die negative gefühl seit der 8
demütigung und auch schmerzt das hatte
auch nach
eine antragsteller demütigung dem wir
die noch dass ich nicht nur zeit und
jetzt könnten positive seite die
praktische schätzung des gesetzes selbst
das ist ein positives gefühl und das
wird kant im folgenden noch als
erhabenheit bestimmen
das wollen wir auch noch mal dann in der
diskussion weiter davor also negativ
überzeugt dass nordenstadt durch die
demütigung unseres rigorismus schmerz
unangenehmes gefühl vielleicht auch ein
bisschen was die scham und im positiven
sinne haben hat weil wir darin unsere
bessere moralische gestiegen
so findet im siepen gesetz unterworfen
sind und zur liebe sein kann auch noch
was mit blick auf die frage ob sie als
moralische triebfeder geeignet ist
es ist sehr schön aus liebe zum menschen
und teilnehmenden wohlwollen ihnen gutes
zu tun oder aus liebe zur ordnung
gerecht sein aber das ist noch nicht die
echte moralische maxime unseres
verhaltens die unsere standpunkte unter
vernünftigen wesen als menschen
angemessen ist wenn wir uns anpassen
gleichsam als volontäre uns mit stolzer
einbildung über den gedanken von pflicht
hinwegzusetzen und als angebot
unabhängig los aus einer lust das tun zu
wollen wozu für uns kein gebot nötig
werden
wir stehen unter einer disziplin der von
uns du wirst in allen unsere maxime der
unter wirklichkeit unter derselben nicht
vergessen ja nichts zu ziehen oder dem
anziehen des gesetzes ob es gleich
unsere eigene gibt durch eigene
beliebigen fahren dadurch etwas
abzukürzen dass wir den bestimmungen
unseres willst wenngleich dem gesetz
gemäß doch wohin anders als im gesetz
ist selbst und in der achtung für dieses
gesetz setzt also warum ist die liebe
nach kann nicht geeignet als moralische
triebfeder deswegen weil wir glauben
dass wir nicht eine geburt ein gesetz
voll müssten was uns übergeordnet ist
sondern in der liebe glauben individuell
als als individuen und auch durch unsere
neigung handeln zu können
bloß aus algen und lustig sagt und das
wäre nach kant eine form der manie weil
hier dann letztendlich wieder nur unsere
neigung mit im spiel sind und uns auch
verwirrend wie im fall des mitleids mir
keinen klaren kriterien der vernunft
haben die unsere handeln anleihen
schiller hat angeschrieben ein diss
tischen das kennen sie vielleicht dass
ich reformiert mal dass er gerne seinen
freunden hilft ist aber leider aus
neigung zu gut und deswegen nicht
moralisch sein kann ja bekannt
jedenfalls mein album sich letztendlich
nicht eignet als moralische trinkt das
muss immer es ein momente unlust mit dem
spiel sein und der haben halt auf der
anderen seite damit wir moralisch
emotional handeln können ja so viel zur
theorie der achtung und der liebe und
des mitleids im unterschied zu youtube
und wir wollen uns jetzt in folge mit
dieser theorie diskursiv weiter befassen